the cardinals will look for a sweep and
they'll go with alex reyes
and basically a bullpen start with alex
reyes having pitched recently
just on saturday so maybe an ending
maybe two
we don't know alex reyes who's on the
hot seat right now
with walks to rizzo kyle schwarber and
wilson contreras
he and half hit a home run in the first
game and he takes one that gets away
trying to score as rizzo he comes in the
score standing up
and the country doesn't know where the
ball is here comes another runner with a
plate and he's going to be out
forever with a dramatic head-first
diving try
but he was out to end the inning the
cubs get a run
without a hit in a major league debut
tyson miller overall last year 7-8 435
at double a and aaa cubs lead one to
nothing bottom of the first the batter
is
tyler o'neil bouncer to third pick by
bryant goes to second there's the force
that's the enemy
and tyson miller has put a zero on the
board in his first big league inning he
gets congratulated by his battery mate
victor caratini
and the tying run is on with brad miller
coming up here's a swing
and a high fly ball center field back to
the track the wall
it's a gunner home run brad miller
that's his first home run of the year
and he has driven in
the last four cardinal runs in this
doubleheader
he had the two rbis in the seventh to
win it and puts the cardinals on top
2-1 in the second inning of game two
he got that one right on the screws that
ball was way out in center field
he's getting the fake high fives from
everybody in the cardinals dugout
that was a pitch up in the zone and he
just smoked it and the pitch ground ball
sharply to rizzo
miller gets over to cover the bag rizzo
dives to the bag did he get there yes
miller was late covering anthony had to
do it by himself
anthony with a dramatic dive to first
just two down it's up to kyle schwarber
the cubs clean up hitter
swinging and a miss he struck him out
good work for sanchez
three strikeouts so far in two innings
of work and that sends us to the bottom
of the third inning
barron's been a very nice addition and
so far throwing the ball
quite well mostly good seven appearances
a 352 era
dylan carlson swang and a miss and
that's going to be strike three out
number one
paul goldschmidt the batter goldschmidt
swings and misses chasing a low bender
you don't get goldsmith to swing at
pitches like that too often so here with
an
excellent slider to get the punch out
two down here's tyler o'neal
swaying in a mess he just struck out the
side so at the plate now is miller
hiller's two-run
shot in the second giving st louis the
lead two to one
and miller hits it the other way that's
well hit again schwarber back
it's gone just over the basket it left
it carries over the wall
and his second home run this one off a
lefty
and what a double-header knight he is
having at
wrigley this is the typical homer in
wrigley line driving the gap that just
stays just above the fence
and that's well hit into right at the
wall
gone back to back home runs and the
first
major league home run for max schrock
takes it over the wall and right
and that makes it a 4-1 st louis lead
max schrock his first major league home
run
now that's a story on top of his story
you say here's my home run ball and you
say
by the way dexter follower my teammate
went into the stands right
people were going to forget that there
was no one up there enesis
cabrera the new pitcher for st louis two
down a man on
cubs trail 4-1 fifth inning brazil loops
on shallow right field but the second
baseman wong will make the catch
and the cubs are still without a hit
through five innings
sixth inning baez at first contrast
drives one in the air to left field deep
back goes o'neal near the wall
that ball is off the base of the wall
and bouncing back toward the infield
fires racing around third he's going to
score on a long double
by wilson contreras and now it's a four
to two ball game
caratini is being called back and i
think david bode
is going to get a chance against tyler
webb and david ross is thinking
long ball a drive into deep center
back on advantage
three run homer david bodies hubs lead
5-4 exactly what the cubs needed was
somebody to break out the big bat and
blast one and it comes to it
one away andrew kisner the batter the
catcher let's see if he can serve up
something that'll force him to hit it in
the ground and
turn a pair here's a bouncer to bryant
he'll glove it short hop tough play
to second for one over to first for a
double play
the double play ends the inning the
redbirds are down to their last
out carlson hits a pop-up foul might be
playable bryant down the line and left
does he have room
yes cubs win hugs have beaten the
cardinals
by a score of five to four